[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a post-apocalyptic science
fiction series called the 100 spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
several years in the future the earth
faces a devastating nuclear apocalypse a
blast of radiation kills most humans and
animals and wipes out all kinds of life
from the earth's surface the survivors
fly to the space stations orbiting the
earth that were then made for the
purpose of space exploration currently
it is 97 years after the apocalypse the
space stations have joined hands to
become one big civilization called the
ark the living situation on ark is not
ideal because of the population growth
and limited resources the people believe
that after a hundred years humans can
return home to the ground although there
are only three years left for the big
day the limited resources threaten the
life of the citizens of the ark hence
the chancellor and the board of
governors have to follow strict rules to
decrease the population immediately
because of this any crime on the ark is
punishable by death except if someone
under 18 is found guilty they are locked
up in a box-like prison one of such
prisoners is clark griffin she is the
daughter of the chief medical officer
abby and the chief engineer of the arc
jake since both her parents are on the
board of governors she is expected to
have privileges but like any other
criminal she is currently locked up
suddenly two guards barge in and make
her wear a wristband they forcefully
bring her out alongside other prisoners
abby stops them for a second to tell
clark that everything will be all right
she is about to land on the earth it
turns out that 100 criminals from the
prisons are being sent to earth's
surface to test its habitability they
could immediately die of radiation or
because of the hostile climate but the
group has no choice whatsoever on the
ship clark meets her childhood best
friend and the son of the chancellor
wells he deliberately committed a small
crime to board the ship to accompany her
however clark doesn't appreciate the
gesture it turns out that her father is
dead and it is somehow wells's fault as
the ship lands a video plays on the
monitor of the chancellor asking them
what they should do when they land they
are tasked to make their way to the
former mount weather emergency
operations center which is filled with
water and supplies enough for 300 people
the ship soon enters the earth's
atmosphere and lands with a crash two
people who had gotten up from their
seats die instantly finn the guy who
urged them to get up is still safe then
we are introduced to the siblings
bellamy and octavia octavia was hidden
under a table by her mother for the
first 16 years of her life because no
one is allowed to have a second child on
the ark bellamy and octavia were
separated when she was caught and their
mother was floated into space the
brother and sister reunite after months
bellamy instantly declares herself the
leader and opens the door to the ship as
the group stands back in anticipation
they are welcomed by a greenery and land
filled with vegetation they run outside
to their home for the first time in
their lives as the group celebrates
clark brings out a map and sees that
they have been dropped some miles away
from mount weather finn follows her
interested in what she is doing back on
the ark one of the members of the
council named kane briefs everyone on
the condition of the 100. because of the
crash they have lost all communication
with the prisoners and will no longer be
able to monitor their location but
because of the wristband their vital
signs are still measurable they see that
two people died while landing but the
plausible explanation could not be a
blast of radiation and just an accident
meanwhile things are starting to get
intense on the ground clark and wells
want to get to mount weather as soon as
possible but the others do not like
being ordered around bellamy and octavia
go against them and claim that they
should go to the mountain and bring back
the supplies they want the privileged to
do the work and not the working class
wells gets into an altercation with a
guy named murphy and hurts his leg
before finn stops the fight bellamy
tells octavia that he did something very
bad to get on the ship if the governors
find out about it they will never
forgive him which means they will have
to make sure to survive on the ground
clark also reveals that if they take off
their wristbands people on ark will
think they are dying and will not come
looking for them this is good news for
bellamy since he can make everyone take
off their bands and form a new
civilization of his own after that
octavia finn clark and two of their
friends jasper and monty set out to look
for the mountain a few minutes later
they come across an animal and watch it
in awe only to then realize it is
mutated and has two heads ah it's cute
meanwhile on the ark abby finds out that
the chancellor has been shot she and her
team of doctors try their best to save
him and use a higher dosage of blood and
anesthesia than allowed for a citizen to
have the guards find out that bellamy is
responsible for shooting the chancellor
which explains why he doesn't want the
officials coming to the ground kane
wants to eliminate hundreds of ark
citizens and save only the ones who are
contributing to their society that way
they can increase the expectancy of
their space station to three years if
more people are not killed they cannot
survive more than four months in the
current living conditions now that he is
deputy chancellor he plans to put his
idea into action meanwhile the group on
the expedition finds a river and jumps
into the water suddenly octavia is
attacked by a strange fish and
snake-like creature jasper jumps to her
rescue and saves her while the others
distract the fish at night everyone at
the camp burns their wristbands at
bellamy's order he asserts his dominance
when wells tries to stop him by now he
has become the leader of the hundred at
night bellamy and his minions forcefully
make wells take his wristband off back
on the arc kane finds out that abby used
more than the legal amount of blood to
save the chancellor using his power as
the deputy chancellor he orders her to
be floated for the crime she is taken
into the airlock and is seconds away
from being sent to space when the
chancellor arrives and stops them he
pardons her and thanks her for saving
his life on earth the team reaches a
river jasper jumps to the other side and
finds an old board showing them the way
to mount weather but just then someone
throws a spear at him that hurts him
gravely the others run back to the camp
to save their lives halfway to the camp
they hear jasper's scream and realize
that he is still alive when they go back
to look for him someone has already
taken him away at the camp things get
heated as bellamy declares there are no
laws or rules murphy goes rogue and
starts a fight with wells they only stop
when the other group arrives everyone is
informed about the dangerous grounders
who took jasper away they decide to be
more careful but are still adamant about
removing the wristbands the next morning
clark bellamy wells and murphy go out on
a rescue mission looking for jasper
since bellamy has a gun they hope to be
safe from the grounders then we are
introduced to a zero gravity mechanic
and finn's girlfriend raven she finds
out that they are not allowing people to
visit their close ones in prison raven
is young ambitious and not afraid of
anything when she realizes something is
off about the new rule she makes it her
mission to find out what she secretly
breaks into abby's lab but is caught on
the way on looking at the screen with
the prisoner's vitals she registers they
have been sent to earth she also tells a
confused abby that the 100 might be
removing the wristbands this helps abby
to present a theory in the next council
meeting at the end of the meeting they
decide to abstain from taking any
decision for 10 more days and to give
the 100 a chance to report back if they
cannot communicate even then they will
have to kill more people on the ark for
the others to survive back in camp
octavia meets monty monty is a
communications expert who is working to
build up connections with the ark he is
also best friends with jasper and hopes
he will be back soon octavia helps him
with his task going against her
brother's rule meanwhile the other team
continues looking for jasper and finds a
waterfall on the way finn and clark seem
to be getting close to each other which
makes wells jealous suddenly they find
jasper's goggles and realize he is
nearby eventually they find him hung
from a tree with his wound treated clark
almost falls into a trap in front of the
tree but is saved by bellamy they bring
jasper down but are attacked by a wild
boar just then wells kills it with the
gun he stole from bellamy i liked this
scene better when it was a polar bear
finally the group has food for the night
and has rescued their friend on the ark
abby asks raven to repair an old escape
pod in nine days planning to return to
the earth to save the others raven
agrees but only if she also gets to go
to the earth with her at night the 100
slaughter the animal and roast it for
food bellamy makes people take their
bands off to get a bite finn gets food
for both himself and clark without
getting theirs off because bellamy's
minions are scared of him the two then
enjoy dinner together the scene cuts to
a flashback clark's father jake the
chancellor and wells are watching a
century-old football match jake gets up
to leave to check a system maintenance
report when he returns later he tells
abby that the ark system is failing and
they have not more than a year of life
support left jake wants to tell the
people what is happening to ensure that
everyone knows about their future but
abby is strictly against the idea since
it will cause panic as they chat clark
overhears their conversation later she
is with wells who notices she is tense
about something clark tells him that her
father is planning to go against the
council's order and tell the people
about the short time they have left
wells promises to not tell anyone
because if they found out jake will be
considered a criminal and will be
floated later that day clark approaches
jake and tells him that she can help him
with his mission however right then the
guards barge in and arrest both of them
since jake is an adult he is floated
immediately while clark is imprisoned
for being his accomplice she assumes
that her best friend told his father
about the secret that got her father
killed on the ground jasper is back but
in very critical condition the grounders
seem to have applied medicine to his
wounds but he will still die if not
given proper medication he moans and
whines in pain causing the others to ask
him to die except that is for the group
that rescued him who tries their best to
make him better clark meets a little
girl named charlotte who has recurring
nightmares about the chancellor
executing her parents she was arrested
for attacking a guard which makes her
hate the chancellor even more three days
have passed since the group rescued
jasper but his health is not getting any
better most of the campers want to kill
him but clark insists there is still
hope she studies the plant the grounders
have used on jasper trying to find more
of it wells who has studied earth's
botany finds out it is seaweed probably
found in a water body that is reddish in
color finn knows a place like that and
brings the others to it on their way
they find a years old automobile with
only its door outside the ground they
plan to explore it later prioritizing
jasper's health first eventually they
find the seaweed but right after they
secure it they are faced with a large
storm of poisonous fog the trio runs
away before getting inside the
automobile to save their lives somewhere
else bellamy and his minions have come
out to hunt he hears a noise from behind
him and throws a spear only to see
charlotte he sympathizes with the little
girl being sent with a bunch of
prisoners and includes her in the hunt
suddenly they are also attacked by the
poisonous clouds bellamy brings the
little girl to a cave and saves them
both but he hears one of his teammates
adam screaming outside at the camp
everyone gets inside the ship to protect
themselves from the clouds finn finds a
bottle of alcohol in the place they are
stuck as they talk the conversation
about clark's father is brought up she
blames wells for betraying her and
causing her father's death wells
apologizes for the hundredth time but it
is not enough bellamy also shows his
good side by waking up a scared
charlotte he makes her understand that
she must kill her inner demons to not be
afraid anymore the next morning the
cloud passes and everyone comes out finn
has discovered that wells is hiding
something about jake's death because he
doesn't talk about it at all he asks
clark to make sure if wells was the one
who reported her father that resulted in
his death somewhere else bellamy finds
adam on the ground his body has been
mutilated because of the poisonous fog
he begs bellamy to kill him not being
able to handle the pain anymore clark
arrives at the right time and hums a
rhythm before stabbing him in the neck
and ending his misery charlotte
witnesses the incident and it leaves a
lasting impression on her the group
returns to the camp at night and
immediately takes care of jasper after
what happened in the woods bellamy wants
to help clark knowing that she is a good
person a while later clark approaches
wells and asks him if he told his father
about jake's plan wells keeps quiet
which only makes clark more nervous she
realizes it was her mother who reported
her father and was the cause of his
death wells just wanted to save her from
misery and took the blame on himself
clark apologizes and cries in his arms
then we see jasper wake up having
recovered because of the medicine he was
given everyone from the group surrounds
him and jokes about the situation as the
vault fills with laughter outside wells
is alone charlotte approaches him and
asks if she can stay by him for the
night suddenly she stabs him in the neck
and hums a rhythm like clark did earlier
she wants to kill him because his father
floated her parents and it is the only
way she can get rid of her demons
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching